y vamos ya con nuestros segundos
invitados del día que iban a hablarnos
desde Jerusalén de todo lo que ha pasado
en esta semana santa para la religión
cristiana pero también una semana muy
importante también para todos los
musulmanes que viven allí en Israel
vamos a hablar con nuestros
corresponsales en Jerusalén y en los
territorios palestinos se trata de
Yanira Gómez Muñoz y también de nuestro
compañero Federico cué Barberena Muchas
gracias a los dos por estar hoy con
nosotros bienvenidos y Antes que nada
quiero preguntaros Cómo se ha vivido en
las calles de Jerusalén esta escalada
a partir de los distintos hechos
que se reforzó la presencia policial con
cuatro unidades de reservistas de la
policía de fronteras hubo patrullaje de
drones también y un y una serie de
cortes de ruta para evitar que se
cruzaran las distintas multitudes de
estas tres grandes religiones
monoteístas así todo las festividades
lograron transcurrir con relativa calma
con normalidad tuvimos por ejemplo unos
130.000 musulmanes empezando el viernes
en la mezquita de anaxa unos 15.000
judíos que participaron
en las bendiciones del domingo en el
muro de los lamentos y también una gran
multitud de cristianos participando en
todas las actividades de la Semana Santa
incluidos muchos turistas en todo
Igualmente en un número según las
autoridades más reducido en parte debido
al temor por estas extensiones bueno
Federico has hablado de la mezquita de
Alexa y quería preguntaros precisamente
por qué algo que ocurre en torno a esta
mezquita genera múltiples frentes de
violencia
estos bombardeos cohetes ataques no solo
hacia israelíes también hacia palestinos
provenientes de colonos israelíes todo
esto tiene que ver con Alexa porque hay
que entender que la Explanada donde se
encuentra es un punto rojo es una línea
roja para eso es un símbolo palestino y
por eso es tan delicado
precisamos que lo que empezó ese
miércoles con esa primera redada que fue
violenta por parte de la policía israelí
había un rumor de que judío o un judío
en Ultra religioso podría llevar un
animal y sacrificarlo allí de ahí que
400 palestinos atrincheraran en el lugar
para protegerlo Y es que esa Explanada
es tan importante tanto para musulmanes
como para judíos que la denominan el
monte del templo y no tienen permitido
ni rezar y mucho menos sacrificar un
animal pero esto por el nuevo gobierno
está siendo alimentado y animado no el
propio ministro de seguridad nacional y
tomar animo a que acudiesen muchos
fieles judíos a caminar por la Explanada
solo pueden hacerlo bajo un cordón
policial luego obviamente no no animó a
que se sacrificaron animal pero el
detonante real fue este no de ahí luego
lo que vimos el desalojo por la fuerza y
toda esta violencia esto ha hecho que el
punto de alaxa que se siente amenazado
ha hecho que muchos lo vean como que
está en peligro no que el símbolo
palestino está en peligro y que por eso
hay que resguardarlo Especialmente los
jóvenes se sienten con ese compromiso y
de ahí todo lo que ha derivado no como
hemos visto una situación de violencia
generalizada en medio de un gobierno de
Benjamín netanyahu que está a punto No
que cumplió ya el sábado 100 días en el
cargo Cómo ha servido todo este contexto
para la llegada de nuevo a netanyahu al
poder bueno por un lado es imposible
de un gobierno el gobierno más radical
de la historia de Israel que tiene una
agenda que busca avanzar sobre el
control de los territorios parecidos
ocupados y
de ser posible llegar hasta la anexión
de estos territorios eso ya de por sí es
un elemento que agrega más a esta
atención y que pone más en alerta sobre
todo los grupos palestinos por otro lado
también habla del momento en el que está
en un momento de una baja credibilidad
entre los israelíes las últimas
encuestas muestran que su imagen
positiva está cayendo fuertemente con
las protestas en las calles y está
impopular impopular proyecto de reforma
judicial y una situación que que permite
pensar en un caos principalmente por
ejemplo la situación con el ministro de
defensaland que fue despedido
públicamente
pero continúa en su cargo porque nunca
se formalizó ese despido y no se sabe
siquiera si se va a formalizar esa esas
situaciones llevaron a que Israel
rápidamente después de estas distintas
distintos frentes que se abrieron
intentar demostrar unidad tanto con
oficialismo como oposición en cuanto a
lo que se trata de la seguridad de
Israel Más allá de que pasado este este
último intercambio volvieron otra vez
las acusaciones cruzadas de un lado y de
otro bueno Yanira y Fede ha habido esta
vez condena internacional ante lo
sucedido Como tantas otras veces pero no
se vislumbra que esto se detenga ni las
redadas ni los ataques de las dos partes
Por qué Y por qué no hay siquiera
perspectivas de un diálogo porque esas
condenas internacionales se un llamado a
retornar a una calma y una estabilidad
que no existe sobre el terreno hablamos
especialmente para la población civil
Palestina ahora mismo Desde el miércoles
no hace ni siquiera una semana ha habido
todo este repunte este pico no que que
se suele llamar pero el cotidiano
realmente es una ocupación y una
violencia constante que afectan a la
población Palestina que solo en este
2023 ha disparado cifras no solo de por
ejemplo de desalojos o derribos de casas
sino también el mayor número de muertos
en un inicio de año no Entonces no hay
tampoco una confianza ni siquiera en el
actual gobierno como describía Federico
con este gobierno hay ninguna
perspectiva de ningún diálogo pero
tampoco del lado palestino la autoridad
nacional Palestina ha perdido totalmente
la credibilidad de la población
Palestina entonces ante este escenario
se hace un poco complicado no hemos
visto aún así tanto en febrero como en
marzo en ácava y en dos intentos de
entre funcionarios israelíes y
palestinos pero más allá del compromiso
no y de estas declaraciones también como
de condenas Internacionales o de
compromiso hacia una paz o una
estabilidad a los dos días o incluso ni
siquiera los propios funcionarios
israelíes al retornar se encontraron con
ministros en el gobierno ministros
israelíes que no tenían ninguna fe o que
negaban que fueran a cumplir aquello
poco que se había acordado no sin ir más
lejos hablamos de no continuar
legalizando asentamientos o de construir
nuevos No eso Por ejemplo que era una de
las medidas no se está teniendo en
cuenta y por ejemplo hoy de hecho
tenemos a ministros en una marcha
reivindicando la legalización de un
asentamiento no entonces todo esto hace
que realmente volver a un estatus es
imposible no Porque la realidad es la
violencia
es un placer tenerlos un poco más
cerquita de este estudio de Bogotá
aunque sea de manera virtual Muchas
gracias por estar aquí y por vuestro
trabajo desde Israel a nuestros
espectadores les invito a que sigan con
nosotros que ya volvemos
[Música]